lawyers for the woman accusing Supreme
Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh of
attacking her in high school are asking
senators to accept new conditions today
so that she can testify christine Blasi
for does not want Kavanagh in the same
room with her and she wants assurances
that she and her family will be kept
safe in an email obtained by CBS News
the lawyers say a demand for a written
statement from Ford by 10:00 a.m.
Eastern today is a non-starter President
Trump praised his nominee again last
night at a rally in Las Vegas Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where the
Senate Judiciary Committee may respond
to Ford's offer later today Nancy good
morning good morning Ford's lawyers
spoke with judiciary staffers for nearly
an hour laying out the terms that they
expect to be met before she testifies
next Thursday at the earliest they want
a say in who goes first and they don't
want Kavanagh in the room when Ford is
questioned Brett Kavanaugh is one of the
finest human beings you will ever have
the privilege of knowing at a rally in
Las Vegas Thursday night President Trump
said he was confident in his Supreme
Court nominee in an interview beforehand
mr. Trump questioned Christine Blasi
Ford's sexual assault allegation against
Judge Brett Kavanaugh why didn't
somebody call the FBI 36 years ago I
mean you could also say when did this
all happen Kavanagh told the Senate
Judiciary Committee last night he wants
a hearing as soon as possible
lawyers for Ford said she can't testify
on Monday but later in the week might
work if the committee meets certain
requests including having her testify
after Kavanagh and having both be
questioned by senators and not outside
Council she also wants the committee to
subpoena mark judge the student Ford
says was also in the room at the time of
the alleged assault CBS News has
reviewed threatening emails sent to
Judge Cavanaugh's wife calling her
husband a rapist and suggesting he put a
bullet in his skull u.s. marshals are
investigating as Democrats asked the FBI
for more protections after death threats
forced Ford and her
family to move out of their home don't
mess with survivors her supporters
rallied on Capitol Hill Thursday
Republicans have rejected Ford's request
for an FBI investigation
they say Democrats should work with them
on a Senate probe instead they're happy
to go in front of the cameras and talk
about asking for an investigation but
when it comes to doing the investigation
there they're not participating
Cavanaugh and his allies have reportedly
been discussing a strategy to question
Ford's memory of her possible assailant
a conservative attorney and friend of
Kavanagh Ed Whelan even speculated
publicly last night that a different
classmate may have been involved and
posted his picture and his name and that
led Ford to give a statement to the
Washington Post saying that she knew
both boys and quote there is zero chance
that I would confuse them Anthony Nancy
Cordes thanks Nancy and Sunday on Face
the Nation John Dickerson will talk with
Republican congressman trey Gowdy and
Democratic congresswoman Anna Eshoo who
was the first member of Congress
contacted by Christine Blasi Ford that's
Face the Nation Sunday here on CBS